this is the one she shot Carol hailstone
is just conquered in a central rite of
passage as a subsistence hunter with
their first ever caribou kill you wanna
tell you that one Carol since that's the
one you shot grab the horses we're
passing right now Carol get it up okay
go Carol and try to put them as tight as
you could so it won't drink
that's your first big bowl button
that was your first pitbull
[Music]
this way towards everybody
[Music]
to shoot you can't aim that one that's
where you always get scolded see right
here where you shot it Oh in the Apple
in the antler this is our last chance of
getting primo bowls what they've done
they've eaten saved all their fat for
the rut and then they quit eating and
they're gonna burn all this fat so this
really is our last chance that something
missed our last chance at fat Bulls so
if I get five she gets five and she gets
five it'll be awesome there next to the
other one perfect baby thank you well
we've got six good caribou it's a good
start for today we've got 500 caribou
writing across forever we're gonna eat
about one every week or two in our house
so this is gonna do us good for part of
winter but winter up here is long and
there's no way I could have enough food
for winter but this is a good start this
is how we get to dark winter until we
can hunt again